[Music]
bombing in the northern city of chernhiv
has intensified
thousands of residents spending another
long night in underground shelters
you can hear the man who filmed this on
his mobile phone say this is absolutely
terrifying
moscow denies targeting civilian areas
but in the village of bashiv less than
40 miles from the capital kiev
these decimated apartment blocks tell a
different story
ukraine has been plunged into a living
hell in less than two weeks
and in a nighttime address to the nation
a war-weary president accused nato of
not doing enough
all the people who die from this day
forward will also die because of you
because of your weakness because of your
lack of unity
today the alliance has given the green
light to the bombing of ukrainian cities
and villages by refusing to create a
no-fly zone
russian bombardments have stepped up in
cities across ukraine
smoke rising from these warehouses just
12 miles from kiev
in his latest address president putin
said there are no bad intentions towards
our neighbors
[Music]
but this is what ukrainians are seeing
a missile exploding over blogger nikita
demenikov as he updated his followers
ukraine's president wants to close the
country's airspace to save its citizens
from attacks like this
but a no-fly zone has once again been
ruled out by the u.s secretary of state
the only way to actually implement
something like a no-fly zone uh is to
send nato planes into ukrainian airspace
and to shoot down russian planes and
that
could lead to a full-fledged war
a third round of talks between ukraine
and russia will be held over the weekend
there's been no breakthrough so far
but a tentative agreement for safe
humanitarian corridors which is
something
why did i leave today because it's
terrifying now there is a threat of a
nuclear explosion
troops are approaching kiev that's why
there's a card like this people just
want to live
it's a devastating sight to witness
another father sending his family to
safety while he stays to fight
this war now into a second week
is wreaking havoc
and heartbreak on a nation
sally lockwood sky news